we turn to the phone lines right now and
find another regular who were thrilled
to have on the program wish wish he was
here because he's always a great in
studio guest when he is here from all
elite wrestling dynamite which airs
Wednesdays at 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time one
of the all-time greats from his
profession the fun the talented the
great Chris Jericho how are you been
Chris rich you know what appreciate that
that's what happens when I'm quarantined
for much of the day Chris you know for
you what's going on with you man you
know what man I'll tell you what like
the one thing that I didn't want to do
is fall into the every day is Groundhog
Day type theory so I've been pretty so
been as creative as I can still doing a
lot of podcasts doing a lot of press
talking to wonderful people such as
yourself thank you sir but the big the
big thing is you know since wrestling is
deemed an essential business in Florida
this we've still been working pretty
much every Wednesday we've been doing a
show so it's been even more unique and
interesting for me
well obviously Chris you know when you
are part of a match that involves you
and Sammy guevara has low sex gods
what's more essential than that Chris by
the way yes you do Chris so does some
other establishments in the state of
Florida so let's let's talk about I mean
that was just set up as a spin curveball
I mean I had to hit that one out of the
park no part of galleries a cookie he
throws a cookie for those who may have
missed the exploits of low sex gods
against Matt Harvey and Kenny Omega walk
us through what happened once again I
mean we're providing you know
entertainment throughout this lockdown
and it's different because we're in it
in the middle of an empty arena which is
very strange because
like a stand-up comedian or a rock and
roll show if you don't have a crowd
that's responding to what you're doing
it's very very strange so right what
we've done in aw is we've placed some of
our staff ringside we work in dailies
place which is connected to the to the
stadium in Jacksonville so there's three
tiers of this kind of big apathy etre so
we can put people in the third to the
second tier and around ring so if you're
doing 1012 people around you know 30
people all included it makes some noise
and when I first started wrestling I
wrestled too a lot less than 30 people
so it does give you some ambience and
also on top of that rather than just
having wrestling match after resting
matches in the ring we're doing some
different stuff where do we did a street
fight last week where we just went and
looked around what was available to us
kind of in this concourse of the
Jacksonville Jaguars Stadium and put on
a pretty fun show and I think if you're
treating it more like a Hollywood stunt
fight like a Hollywood brawl yeah that
you would see in a movie it's much more
entertaining and if you're treating it
just as a wrestling match but there's
nobody there and we can see that there's
nobody there so why bother pretending so
I think that's the idea of what we did
last week with the crazy street fight
and running over each other with golf
cards and doing moonsault soft scissor
lifts and you know garbage cans and ice
machines it's just stuff like that that
you don't normally see but it provides a
unique atmosphere and it's a lot of fun
entertaining
I would ask how you got into the
Jacksonville Jaguars Stadium but we all
know who's behind aw dynamite right on
TNT it's the Khan family Tony and Schad
the son and father combination that owns
the Jacksonville Jaguars
this-this-this aew has been a has been
dynamite it really really has Chris why
do you think it's worked the way it has
well I mean there's a kind of a
combination of factors rich one we're
doing things completely differently from
everybody else any other wrestling
company and that we're letting the guys
basically not
call their own shots well in the the
professionals be professional be
creative and that's where most the stuff
stands from is that we're just being
creative and you know you got guys with
twenty thirty years experience and kind
of know what they're doing so when you
kind of have those chains unlocked it
provides a lot more freedom and a lot
more fun too we have a very passionate
owner in Tony Kahn and and shot as well
as the very supportive but Tony's kind
of spearheading at all yeah and he he
knows what he wants and that's what they
are really appreciate we have a boss who
has passion for the business as respect
for the business but also knows what he
wants it is not swayed by anybody and
you've got a whole crew of guys and
girls who chose not to go anywhere else
who chose to come to aw and take a
chance and we all kind of consider this
our own company because we're the ones
that built it so when you have stake in
it and skin in the game as they say you
have a lot more pride and passion for
what you're doing so if you combine all
those things and also with a great fan
base that has followed us from day one
and hasn't really left I mean we lost a
little bit of our audience but not much
they've been with us the whole way so
it's been a real good kind of
culmination of all these factors of
people being very passionate on both
sides of the camera Chris Jericho here
on the Rich Eisen show Chris you
mentioned how when you started you would
wrestle in front of fewer than 30 people
walk me through the first Chris Jericho
wrestling gig walk me through that one
Chris October 2nd 1990 in panocha
Alberta which is a little town in
between Calgary and Edmonton yep
at the panocha moose hall yes you're
that right - moose hole and it was just
about a mile away from the insane asylum
whatever the politically correct term
for that which was very apropos the fact
that my first wrestling match is very
close to an insane asylum
I worked against Lance Storm who had a
lot of success over the years we were in
wrestling camp together and we had our
first mattress was a ten-minute draw and
it was probably in front of in my mind
it was 10,000 people it's probably you
know 80 or 9
but I just thought it was the greatest
thing ever and I got my paycheck an
envelope that was spelled Jericho wrong
AER ICO and inside was one $20 bill and
one $10 bill I just thought I won the
lottery I'm Aris fan of my life
American or Canadian dollars Canadian of
course with the Pinocchio moose all rich
American I know I just didn't know if it
was for an American outfit that was just
you know in that Hall I didn't even know
what American money look like back in
those days we had them up we have I
think the the $20 bill was Green right
and via $10 bill was it was purple so
and so you got that money and you're
like um I've I've made it so when when
did you hit the big time when did you
when did that happen because every level
that you get you which is bigger than
the last is the big time you know to me
the first time I went to Mexico was the
big time but the first time I was in
Japan etc etc if you're talking about
when did I get to the big time in the
States well that's 96 for WCW with with
Ted Turner but I had been in the big
time in Mexico working arenas there as
early as 1992 you know I'm working
arenas and stadiums in Japan 94 95 so
every level is different from the last
and one thing about a true Pro is even
to this day is that you always want to
get to the next level you always want
want to do more and I think it's one
reason why I'm still here is I still
have that passion that fire to continue
to create continue to succeed and get to
that next level of what's the big time
for Chris Jericho in 2020 we're seeing
right now the last dance don't know if
you've been watching any of that stuff
on ESPN involving Michael Jordan Chris
and about just the sheer hatred that
Jordan still has years later for the
Detroit Pistons you could see it you
could feel it you could taste it you
could just it was it's all over the
documentary is there anybody that you
particularly truly dislike from back in
the day that right now it just gets you
all seething professional because now
that we're home looking for shows to
watch with our families and our wives
and yes I suggested the last dance I'm
always like basketball
no no way so I'm gonna have to watch
that one on my own but I'm
I think that there were guys in the past
that I had issues with I mean Triple H
is one of them he'll tell you the same
in the early 2000s we didn't have much
like for each other but we always had
great matches and I think this might be
one of the reasons why we just had this
professional rivalry maybe a little
personal dislike but then you know fast
forward four or five six seven years you
get to be you know a little bit older
and wiser you expect like why why did we
have so many problems why do we hate
each other why do we not like each other
and then you know now we're friends and
I think it's there's a lot of
professional rivalry when you're when
you're young and full of vim and vigor
as they say it happens in rock-and-roll
bands all the time the bands will break
up and you know ten years later get back
together wonder why do we waste ten
years of our lives not playing together
so I think that there's always that
little bit of that animosity that drives
you to become better and if you have a
case like let's say Jericho and Triple H
our matches were always great because
there was a little bit of real-life
animosity between us I'm going to show
him well I'm going to show him well I'm
going to show him and I think that's
good in a certain way and I would almost
suggest that back in those days that
Vince McMahon would would subtly
encourage that because he knew you're
always gonna get better results inside
of the ring well I mean again the last
dance is about you know those Jordan
years if we could do a ten part
documentary from your world what what
what I guess 10 15 years span do you
think you'd like to see a documentary on
Kris you know I think probably the best
the best career I ever had I mean the
first eight years was was good I think
when I turn into kind of the suit and
tie big words using Jericho in 2008 up
until now I mean that's pretty much
there's your 12 years since I've had a
couple years on the back end but that's
kind of I think the highlight of my
career and probably the most interesting
part of my career with all the longevity
and the chances that I took and the
changes that I made you know basically
changing the business
when I signed with aw the whole whole
business changed at that point in time
so that's kind of I think they'd make a
great kind of a story there of a section
of a guy's career who always gave his
all but wasn't afraid to take a few
chances and ruffle a few feathers along
the way you the man Chris Jericho you
hang in there you stay safe and we'll
just keep following you on Twitter at I
am Jericho and then on Instagram at
Chris Jericho Fozzy for your heavy metal
band Fozzy
yes sir rich and I look forward to
seeing it in the future person and tell
nick swardson that i want to hear him
tell you a fart joke okay let me write
that down
a fart jokes are the best okay you got
it Chris I aim to please thanks for
calling in you take care of yourself you
aim to please thanks rich no that's
Chris Jericho